well with Millie let me see that I'll
show you an example he said
that I wanted to thank you Iran
isn't it amazing to have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up
looks pretty well this was done by the
military given to me
um I think we can probably yeah we'll
we'll have to see yeah we'll have to try
to figure out see as president I could
have did less yeah no I can't you know
but this is yeah we have a problem is
that interesting this is according to
the Liberals and the Trump haters on the
right the proof that Donald Trump
committed the crime and the evidence
that the prosecution needs to send him
to prison forever except it isn't and
the way that I know it isn't is that
those documents referenced in the leaked
conversation aren't the documents that
Trump is accused of mishandling